al good morning how are you top of the
day I love be a question you ask case
keenum about if he was in full uniform
walking through Hollywood would anybody
recognize me it's very appropriate
thanksgiving of course before
thanksgiving we've got halloween coming
up so that would be that was very
interesting what is missing but would
recognize him when's the last time you
sick sick doubt that you missed missed
an event who I don't want to knock on
wood I don't want to as they say in
Yiddish give myself a ken ahora but I
haven't missed an assignment ever uh
well not that I was supposed to be a
part of with that I think my sister got
married about 30 years ago and they gave
me the day off which was very nice of
them okay uh but apart from that no I've
been able to play heard Dan like much as
you did in Sochi yeah or didn't because
I had to fill in for you for three or
four days you know they were gonna give
me like a commemorative Olympic gold
medal for that and I said no I didn't
want that but you were there and you saw
how sick I was out my my favorite
memories of sochi the Olympics in 2014
uh was not Bob's favorite memory of
course because our colleague mr. Costas
developed some form of pink eye and was
in the room between ours so as I had to
pass by his room to get to the elevators
every day I would climb the wall on the
other side of the hall may you got the
flu but the best part of that or at
least he might my favorite memory would
be going to the gym I think you were
sick for three or four days on the
second day I go down to the gym after I
sneak by kostas his room and Lester Holt
is having a workout the likes of which I
had never seen the great Lester Holt the
Supreme anchor of NBC Nightly News is
working out as if he is training for
either the Green Berets or to fight the
heavyweight champion of the world marine
push-ups and the whole thing and there
is one mr. dan Patrick in his bath
robe uh glassy-eyed uh absolutely beyond
under the weather in all caps and
exclamation points and I'm Stairmaster
yeah I will never forget that you still
have that bathrobe with you yes I do if
you took it right out of the closet at
the this the radisson the lovely I don't
know if it's still there in Sochi I I
don't know if sochi's still there al ah
you know they built this you know Oh
complex and the resort and I guess
haven't had a grand prix race or
something that we have some formula 1
race over there and I don't know I mean
I mean to me it just I mean they did a
nice job they pulled off the Olympic
shin unless we get those were the
Olympics where uh your terrorism with
front and center in the media and the
great Richard Engel the NBC foreign news
correspondent came by one day and he
said you know why is nobody here and I
said Richard because you scared that's
true every article had to do with
terrorism and we're all going to die al
I didn't even leave I went to the hotel
the broadcast Center and then I would
come back and I repeated that I think
for about 17 days I never even went into
downtown Sochi because our scene either
our security expert said you know you
can't go in there unless you go in there
I have to go in there with you and we
have to have military clearance we have
to sweep because the restaurant I went
oh my god yea mostly that we had our own
persecuted detail and it was a guy who's
a SB Matt coughing there I'm like Fritzi
now he must have sent it to the phone
line here we had a guy who somebody had
brought over and he written a book about
security and Sochi and all of that and
he kept calling himself the colonel he
was a colonel in the someplace I don't
know where it was but he was from
Kentucky so naturally i named him
colonel sanders and that was that was
not as that is London where we had
dinner every night nor as good as real
where I only saw you on weekends but we
did go to that cholesterol palace
restaurant two or three you love that
though I i got i told the dance I said I
don't
what the name of the place was but they
were carven beef and that's all you
needed and and they would do it about
every five seconds they would come by
with you know it didn't matter what it
was porterhouse filet tenderloin
whatever then the chicken came by and
then they had sushi and it was the place
was jammed every night as you know as
you remember yes and it was it was
wonderful that mean that was that was
heaven for me I mean every five every
five minutes of guys coming by with a
skewer and the thing and you know and we
takin the tongs and it was it was
phenomenal he's Al Michaels NBC Sports
joining a Stan Patrick show the den ants
loved now I wasn't able to listen to all
of this but the second half fill
material when the Steelers are bro
lowing out the Chiefs you and Chris all
of a sudden like the game is secondary
but at what point do you you go into the
treasure trove of memories and start
talking about things that maybe aren't
applicable to the game itself well let's
put it this way there are different
points when you do that one of those
points would be when the halftime score
is 29 to nothing because you are
thinking about people especially in the
eastern time zone and there's not a lot
of drama so if you're going to sit there
and do strategy and it twenty nine to
nothing game you're not going to have
listeners for very long but much longer
or viewers and it's not as if you ignore
the game you talk about things that you
try to talk about things that are inside
the game itself for what it's worth is
that point and there are a lot of
stories that we can tell me alejandro
Villanueva the left tackle of Pittsburgh
is a great story you know Michele Tafoya
had a couple of stories as she was able
to tell you do that and then you play
around a little bit and then also the
other night we had actually had the
pieces ready to go because Arnold Palmer
to die the week before so we had a
little retrospective about mr Palmer I
believe the services today in latrobe
Vin Scully had retired that day from the
Dodgers and Dick Enberg who was a long
time NBC broadcaster as well as doing
the angels and now the San Diego Padres
for the last several years dick was
retiring
well so you know we were able to try to
keep you know we want to do that anyway
with with dick inventing and with with
Arnold but you know that particular
point maybe you expand a little bit uh
but I mean you know you can't sit there
and go you know here's what they're
thinking about third and three down by
29 points VIN Scully's genius was what
Benny's genius was a lot of things I
mean first of all he did this for 67
years I said to Chris on the air the
other night bisa prompt into my head
that who has a 67 year career in
anything names Somebody Anybody an
executive factory worker six that's 67
years it's next to impossible because
you have to start when you're about 20
the guy that came to mind who was at the
top of his own saying the top of his
game for all of those years was Don
Rickles Don Rickles started as a
comedian in his early 20s and he still
did a one-man show that I went to last
January and he is still very close to
the top of his game then he had a
tremendous connection with the the
audience he went through generations of
Dodger fans look I listened to him since
I was six years old I grew up in
Brooklyn we move to LA concurrent with
the Dodgers so I've heard many men in
our life and the great the unbelievable
thing Dan is that I mean as recently as
a month ago you know I'm driving home
coming off the freeway and listening to
Vinny call again it's the Dodgers in the
Rockies in late august or whatever it
was it didn't mean anything he didn't
mean much and Vinny selling a couple of
stories and I all I know is I got into
my driveway and I don't open up the
garage door because I need five more
minutes to hear of any finish the story
so the car is idling and I'm thinking to
myself this is unbelievable I was
listening to this this man do this in
the early 50s and now I'm hearing it in
2016 and you know it's funny B's bob
costas and I we were in Pittsburgh the
other day and I went on the slingbox and
we just happened to catch Bob and I
caught Vinny's last like 15 minutes of
doing the Dodger giant game the other
day it was phenomenal and I'm thinking
to myself why is he retiring now i
understand that i mean he he was
phenomenal the other day uh it's as good
as any broadcast I've ever heard Ben do
but I do get the fact you know it's one
thing to say hey you know you
you can really interaction it up for the
end of your career another thing I'm
sure you know if any would look ahead
and say you know I've got to do 100
games next year the god bless him he's
been amazing it's it's it I mean I was
there an opening day when they honored
and they asked me to emcee the ceremony
you couldn't believe it I mean that the
fans were going crazy for ten minutes
and I wasn't here for the the the last
game he did at Dodger Stadium were and
ended with a home run uh remarkable I
mean he's a freak of nature that's the
only way I can put it that he there's so
many things that made him so great but
he is the connective tissue with
generations of Dodger fans I was also
talking to the den it's about this we're
talking about Odell Beckham jr. and how
you know the way games are produced now
it's a reality show you have storylines
personalities you focus on the stars no
matter what keep a camera on them no
matter what but can you take us behind
the scenes of sunday night football with
Odell Beckham jr. and how that story
line you think plays out or how you
cover somebody like that who can be
animated controversial colorful dramatic
all of that in its span of a three hour
broadcast well we have him this week in
fact so the Giants go to Lambeau Field
and you know you know Fred gadelha our
producers the best I've ever worked with
maybe the best of all time I say sports
producer maybe as a producer period they
should have him do the Oscars and every
other big show I'm sure for fred is
thinking and our thought process is
similar people want to know what Beckham
is up to so a lot of this is driven by
what is the audience want to see and a
lot of it because of Beckham's
comportment over the past couple of
weeks you know he's going up against
Josh Norman we see him last night we see
the meltdown where you know the kicking
that almost could decapitate some on the
sideline so there there is a curiosity
factor so you can't ignore it you don't
want to overplay it but people are
interested in what is going on and look
television can take you places where you
can't go so
was a consequence there's nothing that
the fan I don't want to say relish is
more but needs to see as much as like a
sideline confrontation I hate to admit
it because you know you want to say that
the game is the thing and the game is
the thing but they're all these subplots
now and you can get a camera just about
everywhere and then you know it's like
it's almost as if look there are so many
shows now that are around the game not
ours not yours of course not football
night because we are you know that's
that's the the gold standard thanks to
you but the the situation is hey let's
make an hour out of whatever it is and
let's argue about it and we'll have a
little bit of light but we'll have a lot
of heat and this is how you know the
National Football League and frankly all
sports them has become around the clock
all year long doesn't matter what how
long the offseason is we've got
something to talk about we've got crazy
stuff to talk about and so you do try to
walk that fine line though Dan where you
know you don't overplay it but people
want to see what's going on maybe
nothing happens if nothing's going on
then our cameras probably won't be
focused there very long if something's
going on they will be focused there and
sometimes we'll focus on something if
nothing's going on because we expect
something to go on but we're showing
that nothing's going on and that's what
the storyline is that's that's exactly
right you know it's like covering the
national anthem these days what do you
want to do with this now I mean
everybody who's kneeling who's putting
the right fist in the air whose do maybe
nobody's doing anything so as we're to
the point now where most games opening
weekend to think everybody covered the
anthem now i think monday night covered
it last night but we're to the point now
we're in a commercial break during the
anthem and most of the other telecasts
are but you feel you know you can't
lecture people as to what's going on but
they want to see what's going on so you
have to cover it you think you could
broadcast for another 20 years ah
another 20 years could you do what Ben
is doing that yeah I don't think
so I hope so um you know so it's a
little different I think you know when
you're the the team announcer there's
this tremendous connection I mean you're
part of the family and I think one of
the differences between node Vinny's
done all these years and and what I've
done is all of my work is on national
television so I'm not part of the family
to the extent that you know that Vinnie
could be maybe people know how ok it's
Al's on the air something like football
you know all those years was Monday but
you know maybe they're happier there
maybe they're not happier they maybe
don't give a damn uh with the team
announcer you're in the family I mean
you you might as well be the you know
the brother the father the uncle you're
there every night and then he's been
there so it's a little different for me
I mean I you know I'm kind of like I've
got to be the neutral observer in a way
where Vinnie you know then he comes with
the team he was popular Dodger is
anybody including Koufax Drysdale you
name it through the years sixty seven
seasons unbelievable I'll leave you with
this the dentists have a bet what did
you have for dinner last night I had
sliced veal and we worry your favorite
place in mine as well and Norman Lear
happened to be in there last night but
there's no I to feel the way I mention
that you know all the family is the
number-one show and we're trying to be
the number-one show for 68 years to tie
american idol is here and you know it'll
be it'll be a little bit of a struggle
this year because when you have blowouts
like we had Sunday night that's not good
we go against the debate on Monday night
I hope people will tape the debate watch
the giants and packers live mental well
and I hope you have a Neilsen book will
be will be watching and listening on
Sunday night there and I'll be watching
thank you bud go talk to you all right
that's al michaels tenants were correct
al had meet the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you